coração the Cayman Islands and Dora
leashed enstein and Jersey these are tax
havens where companies and rich
individuals come to park their money
anonymously knowing they won't get
caught all it takes is a p.o box a bank
account and a few front men
this witless done Champions League or
we're talking about champions league
world class stuff that's going on over
there they have real experts at work and
when they do their job well it's almost
impossible for in-house tax fraud
investigators to uncover anything the
phone Soulja teeing off today Frank ver
Heim spent years hunting down tax
evaders he's published a book detailing
his experiences as head of tax
investigations in Germany's banking
center Frankfurt not all that far from
the European tax havens full friendly
was none his looks on both where did the
tax haven start is Luxembourg a haven is
Switzerland Liechtenstein is of course
but then you have Austria with its
banking secrets that's also a drama I
luqman then there's the Isle of Man in
Ireland isla de cannoli I haven't even
mentioned the Channel Islands yes this
is Europe when you think about it it
seems it's just being allowed to happen
faster for ducked off it's less indeed
you was known by silverstein nobody
knows exactly what or how much is
deposited in offshore accounts the Tax
Justice Network estimates there's more
than twenty trillion euros hidden away
and while many tax havens may be legal
failure to declare the accounts is not
in 2011 Finance Minister Wolfgang
schäuble came up with a compromise
agreement with Switzerland german
taxpayers hiding money and swiss banks
would have their accounts taxed at a
flat rate but their identities would
remain hidden Germany's federal states
rejected the plan the anson Linda
Stephens is the government really
serious about fighting tax evasion yeah
I know if you want to sign a deal with
Switzerland at the end of the day just
serves to reassure tax evaders and banks
there you can't say that you're actually
trying to stop anything him does have a
class what he none of it know about
Volta boyens finance minister in the
state of North rhine-westphalia thinks
public pressure is the right way to go a
series of leaks have unco
information on hundreds of thousands of
illegal offshore accounts and their
holders information that ends up in the
hands of investigators that sends an
important message nobody's hidden
accounts are safe that's put pressure on
tax havens to Estes it started with the
first revelation that there were CDs of
data being sold but also investigation
is like the offshore leaks which created
a lot of uncertainty and made people
think twice that a falafel wolf notice
that the country's we're talking about
or at least a lot of them don't want to
be saddled with a bad reputation forever
to a filha that's what's happening right
now and then zulay should move to have
yet to become the world the business
model for tax havens is based on secrecy
exchanging information with tax
authorities around the world would
destroy their business so investigators
find it nearly impossible to get
anywhere
scootin wash there's only one thing you
can do investigate anything that comes
out of these havens for tax fraud then
you take a closer look at what's legal
and what's not that would clear out the
tax haven business fast so gosh if nivek
from stoya was that's exactly what has
happened in some of Europe's tax havens
little by little countries like
Luxembourg Switzerland and Austria are
starting to give up valuable information
on their bank account holders in Germany
tax evasion has become a hot campaign
topic Social Democrat candidate peer
Steinbrueck is reminding voters of his
hardline stance against switzerland
where he was finance minister in the
last government he demanded Swiss banks
cooperate with authorities the Magnus of
langson you can tell by the reactions
were seeing suddenly the luxembourg
finance ministers saying he could
imagine automatically sharing financial
information the swiss banks are saying
they want to get active themselves how
state and vine ons Ava activa this
much-maligned lose them as these are
hard nuts to crack and if you try to
force it you just hit a wall with
negotiations you don't get any further
von traumen veto and Vita played Mandy
dinghy dock fun so said shy blah at a
meeting with the US Treasury secretary
the US has threatened to block offshore
banks from the lucrative US market
slowly that pressure seems to be working